it turns out it wasn't a ghost at all it
was my little sister hiding in the
basement oh shoot I forgot his juice
boxes oh I will be right back
you'll be all right with that I think so
okay so Zachary you know I'm gonna be
marrying your mother and I'm gonna be
moving in soon and that just I'm so
excited to spend more time with you you
know I know that you had a hard time
with your father
and Eddie spanked you I just want you to
know that's not gonna happen with me
okay and I promise I will never spank
you
oh okay that's okay um
I know why you did that but I will never
spank you because I know that you still
oh that's I don't know that there's
anything I did to deserve that
oh hey okay I'm gonna be real with you
you can't go hittin people all right oh
oh oh I'm coming back for that fourth
one all right so we done we got that out
of our system cuz I know that this this
isn't you
oh I told you you want oh that's
unbelievable I'm the good guy
um I'm the good guy um look I'm never
gonna spank you I'm not gonna be like
your father I'm gonna be your friend
you need to respect me you understand
[Music]
I will respect you Charles if you play
your role now listen up
I'm a bad bad boy Charles
I don't need a friend
so go ahead marry my mommy move in there
as hard as you want just leave me the
alone you do that 11 years from now I'll
be out of the house and we won't have
any problems
you don't and I will break you
okay Charles
[Applause]
how are we doing
you